welcome to this video playing hard off
from Israel playing a bit of a faux at
the moment on some change played lots of
kilos openings in recent weeks and have
haven't played before that much okay we
cut a Sicilian con variation let's see
what blacks doing now I playing this so
yeah I have only very wake knowledge
here should I place afore maybe I should
I mean not like that it's a necessarily
the theoretical but at least it leads to
a position type that I have some
experience in serve the Hedgehog um yeah
should I go f4 f5 quickly here yeah
let's let's let's try it but so probably
a play will move playable option okay I
wonder I wonder if I should play a 5
he's got a five and probably be five I
think I should probably lend some
protection to the knight on c3 so that
b5 and d5 moves are tougher for him to
to play okay I'm so f five now not quite
sure maybe some more
precautions against the b5 and d5 but
now let's let's do that you can of
course the void if I have certainly with
moves like night see 5 or 9 f 5 yeah
this is one of the moves what now yeah
well I'm protecting a form quite enough
so I'm dropping back it's not that I
necessarily want to secure the bishop me
being a fan of the bishops but I want to
prepare before him Texas technically
justified before would be strategically
quite dubious to weaken c4 but before
would push the night back to d7 and then
I can just take on e6 so I'm with Bishop
be one trying to intensify the pressure
against e6 sort of trying to play
against the protector of this porn not
quite sure what you should do now of
course you can play if five after all
but I'm not sure that this was his
intention does not look like that with
most like night c 5 2 p-8 okay it's
doing it he's doing it so okay night see
to blunder c4 so I need to go home back
to f3
yeah that's not at the end of the world
for black concern still seems perfectly
viable what's my plan here well he tries
to play b5 this is quite clear from the
zoo also I wonder should I am yeah well
before I couldn't play before yeah I
mean it's not after he has played queen
bee ate before is getting a bit more
attractive why can also night I can also
play a brutally on GG flowers g4 and
stuff but that's Queen aah yeah okay I
probably probably want to avoid that
okay maybe put put the CL attacking b6
and yeah okay I also need it to play
move at some point cannot let the clock
run down so much
yeah I'd not sure maybe yeah but taking
it yeah he avoided the CAPTCHA trying to
try to play I get get counter play with
be five I wonder if I can actually take
on his seven play Bishop g5 hmm is this
a move I don't know Jaheim I'm doing
that intending Bishop f6 sir to to
worsen his pawn structure on the
kingside around the king if he goes 97 i
think i'm going to grab be five I don't
really see the compensation then okay
staking here so my idea was to take on
f6 and take root in Group C form yeah or
should I go Group C for first no let's
do that first
yeah yes this is somewhat suspected I'm
really not sure about the consequence
because I can now switch over with my
rock to the to the king to g4 and Queen
d2 probably check Oh is there something
even more forceful 22mm Queen d2 if I go
22 Bishop f3 rook f3 rock dat background
is a bit weak maybe I should go here
actually
Queen age six is a threat I think you
must take on a three I don't know
probably not the only move but it's the
probably what I would have played now
but I would play now Bishop a three
rookie of three rookie aid wow really I
can go here now rook GA that taken a g5
and that's it I think check what does he
have Bishop g2 this kind of sick defense
yeah ask that Wow there should be two
kindred too windy to check that sick now
when I go back I go back here time
morning i hope i think it's still
winning
check going to h1 check Queen takes root
g one is easy and if it takes with the
pawn I cannot play f6 because my queen
is hanging how sick is that hello my
queen is not hanging nonsense f6f this
this was i calculated this correctly so
f six but he still got this bloody check
on d5 okay my initial I need to do it
anyway okay I only hope that I can I can
get out of this chair and it would have
been somewhat unfair if it's not a twin
I think somehow check
now that's not a chick buddy black
wizard mate I need to go to d4 of course
I was just trying it's it's a think it's
a draw no it's not a draw check how do I
avoid it actually so okay Jess this the
check then I can go to g3 ok I can go to
g3 so I'm winning I was still totally
irritated yeah this is the draw this is
the wrong check so it's a draw check
after this move ok I need to go here I
was yeah to be honest I was irritated by
this but this is actually very simple ok
ok I can chat and here i can't go up
this is the big deal here i can go up ok
then then this this hold stuff with 95
was a win and in fact i think then it's
after Queen III already highly critical
I could have won our Queen d2 was
winning ok yeah I had the suspicion but
i ah the g porn can take this notice i
didn't didn't really consider because I
was so fascinated by getting both rooks
into the play but here the week back
rank is a big issue I cannot go here
like not that made of course but I can
take with the pawn this is actually a
win yeah okay the problem is that check
this is a total over load
ko ko Kim yeah then he cannot really go
t5 this will check seems to lose then
with with because of this is here he has
got 97 at the computer says it's still
defensible ok now the evaluation goes up
very up very much of it looks looks too
dangerous odds that really looks too
dangerous ok well interesting game
thanks for watching